what are we making today what can we
learn from bobby flay
i'm just so excited i'm your student
just to sort of tie this into you know
what nacho's been up to one of his
secret ingredients and
his food is bone broth so we're gonna
make a shrimp pasta
utilizing shrimp broth to really bring
in lots of flavor
you take the shells you put some water
in some tomato paste some some aromatics
like onions whatever
and then and then in about a half an
hour you have very very flavorful
shrimp shrimp broth and it's free it
comes with the shrimp so you might as
well use it
and you have great flavor so we're going
to start with the pasta now there's a
rumor out there that you don't like the
shape of work yet
is that true um you know what it's not
that i don't like it
i hate it really i don't get it
because i'm like it's literally i'm like
don't give me all that carbohydrate
without being able to like
string the noodles i don't know they
just really irritate me
but you just don't like the shape of it
you don't like the shape of it i don't i
don't like the mouth
feel i i but you're bobby flay so i was
like guess what
if anyone's going to like turn my aura
ketty story around it's going to be you
that's a lot of pressure drew i know
i'll take the challenge i know i'm a
dramatic girl bobby you know that
i know that's why i love it i love you
too okay so we're gonna start cooking
some shrimp
uh we have some salt and pepper and
we're gonna put the shrimp right in the
pan a little bit of oil in the pan
and you have a hot pan and you put the
shrimp in there and just make sure that
they're
sort of they're not on top of each other
they each have their own little space in
the pan
bobby you actually did we have a clip
here a tape
clip and i'm really excited because it's
very informative
about said shrimp i'm going to roll that
really quickly so everybody can watch it
so you want to buy and prepare shrimp
but don't know where to start
here are some simple shrimp tips don't
be afraid to buy shrimp frozen the
majority of so-called
fresh shrimp you see at the store were
flash frozen and thawed for display
it's better to defrost them yourself as
for pre-cooked shrimp
just say no they tend to be dry and
bland when added to dishes
you can buy shrimp in three varieties
shell on
which costs the least but can take more
time to prep easy peel
which have been split and deveined and
pre-peeled shrimp are easiest to prep
but pricier now let's get those shrimp
prepped
to thaw frozen shrimp place in a bowl
under cold
not warm running water for just a few
minutes then dry
devein the shrimp with a paring knife or
shrimp de veiner
and those are our simple shrimp tips
enjoy your crustacean creations
so we're going to take our so our shrimp
is about you know three quarters of the
way cooked at this point we're going to
take the shrimp out
and reserve them on a plate and in the
same
pan we're going to take the garlic
and some of the crushed red peppers just
just
just a pinch of the uh of the crushed
red peppers
and you just want to um you just want to
kind of move the garlic around
because you don't want it to burn and
then you're going to take some of the
shrimp broth that we have
you should have some shrimp rot there
put the heat on high and then let it
let it cook you want it to reduce a
little bit just kind of bring it to a
boil
and then as it starts to come to a boil
we're going to add the shrimp back to
the
back to the shrimp broth
i'm waiting till it gets to a boil right
so the shrimp
will finish cooking in your broth with
the garlic and all those chilies and
everything
and the and the and the and the uh the
shrimp rock is really
what's gonna bring tons of flavor to it
we are making shrimp or
chiate with the best chef in the world
bobby flay
and the shrimp broth has been boiling
and simmering and it smells
so good okay and now bobby where are we
at is it time to add our oriquetti
uh yes we can add some marquette to here
right about now
it should be cooked perfectly okay and
i'm going to
strain it out a little bit add some more
there
and then this is when the pasta and the
shrimp and the broth really start to
come together
and then we have some fresh herbs
i have some fresh basil here some fresh
parsley
and you always add fresh herbs through
whenever you're cooking something warm
it can be anything it'd be a pasta or a
rice dish
or a soup or whatever it is whenever
you're going to add fresh herbs you
always want to add them at the very very
end so they stay nice and bright
and really green not so can you keep it
down right there and then
we're going to add a little bit of
butter yep there's some richness
a touch of parmigiano-reggiano cheese
um now bobby i actually learned a very
tough lesson the first time i was with
your girl
giada and then i redeemed myself
on our second hang which is that you
don't it's not a good idea to put the
cheese in
while the pan is on the heat you want to
do it
after otherwise it turns into gooey
snotty cobwebs it's basically right
very very last second basically you just
want the parmigiano to kind of just kind
of melt in
it's almost like it's almost like you're
seasoning it as you're bringing it off
the uh
off the heat into the into the bowl so
you're almost
almost treating it like like some salt
for instance you know just like that
uh if you have a lemon there if you want
to put a little lemon zest on top that's
obviously optional i kind of love
the brightness of lemon like a shrimp
pasta
okay i'm putting my cheese on and
um do i get to taste it now yes
let's do it all right you're gonna be
the let's see
it's really light but the shrimp stock
really brings in tons of flavor
all right it's amazing
oh my gosh bobby what
why is this orecchiette different
there's something i'm not kidding maybe
this is a
a new life for orchiette for you
i knew if there was one person that
could turn me around
it was you and i'm completely turned
around and i'm not just saying this i
thought it'd be really funny if i didn't
like it
it would almost make for a better
segment but of course i'm in
love it's so good thank you so much
oh my gosh bobby you've changed my life
okay by the way
do you know what pasta i hate even more
than orakiete
what's that papara delay really
yes will you please please do a papara
deli dish cause that pasta peeves me to
no end
you like mushrooms love
yeah i'll i'll teach you a paper deli
with mushrooms which is just amazing
you've totally changed me now i want to
attack pepra delete because
i don't know what it is i just have a
visceral reaction to it
i think i'm like a child of the 80s from
california i like a nice box spaghetti i
do love fresh pasta
i love a ravioli i love a tortellini
okay bobby
i hear that we have a little surprise
for our kittens
who are up for adoption yes at brooklyn
uh animal action
so nacho is uh graciously donating
a bunch of food to uh to the brooklyn
animal action
uh because
he cares about cats everywhere i mean
and um
he wants every cat to have a really good
home and and have good health so
uh we're really happy to be
participating in that as well
well peach and i just want to say that
we absolutely send all of our love over
to you and nacho